We've all imagined it:...
...a world where robots do every job going.
Well, imagine no more, because in a remote part of Japan,...
...some sense of that future can be experienced at a robot hotel.
Welcome to the Henn-na Hotel.
Enjoy your comfortable stay.
I will enjoy my comfortable stay.
Thank you, robot.
Japan already employs over a quarter of a million industrial robot workers,...
...more than any other nation, in an effort to counter high labor costs.
Big business would like to see that number go up to a million over the next 15 years.
But as developers get better at building humanoid robots,...
...bosses in the service and entertainment industries,...
...are eyeing up ways to automate their workforce, too.